donna's like a prayer music video turns
30 and ET actually had i know i know he
actually had the exclusive first look at
the video all the way back in 1989 and
believe it or not we had our own
controversy getting it on the air our
exclusive world premiere of Madonna's
brand-new video the song like a prayer
it was this week thirty years ago that
et first debuted like a prayer we had no
idea what the video's theme would be
only that it was delivered just before
the broadcast producer Lou Murray
screened at first I remember snatching
the video and running into an edit Bay
and handing it to the editor and I
started watching it and we looked at
each other and I went oh I don't know
that we're gonna be able to air this we
were all watching and going oh my god oh
my god
we stayed away from the burning crosses
but we were the first ones to see it and
we knew it was gonna be a big story it's
hard to put into context just how much
Madonna backlash followed once the full
video was released later that day go
ahead make a wish within days
Pepsi dropped her five million dollar
contract it may go down as one of the
most expensive advertising blunders ever
the Vatican even tried to boycott her
Blonde Ambition world tour in Italy they
are trying to keep people from seeing it
the backlash didn't stop like a prayer
from becoming one of Madonna's most
iconic hits well no risk no glory she
took to Instagram to commemorate the
30th anniversary saying quote made a
video that caused so much controversy
because I kissed a black Saint and
danced in front of burning crosses happy
birthday to me and controversy
[Music]